yeah dude right up bro yeah
matches the devil yeah you know what i
listen don't think i haven't noticed
that every time i come in here your your
boy scout kerchief matches whatever
color's on your shirt
you gotta you gotta keep it fresh oh
yeah what's going on brother uh
man i was in nashville this weekend uh
for shows or just looking around just
looking around
and thoughts great city great we saw
something we love
there's only a few places where if
you're gonna leave california
it's nevada arizona
texas and nashville outside that you're
really especially for what we're doing
that's what i'm saying yeah if you're in
the business the biz
yeah those are really the only right you
want to save money
because i don't want to go to new york
can't go to new york i can could you do
one of those winners
oh absolutely not meaning i'm from
denver dude i can't do it
i couldn't talk about no i couldn't do a
boston winner no man a denver winner
and you know what's funny is people
always say but you're from
jews and i'm like yeah it was [ __ ]
cold when i lived there too yeah i
learned my lesson that's why i
never want to deal with that again
waking up in the morning scraping out my
window
was of the car the worst start to the
morning
ever do you know what we used to do as
kids though
because everybody would let their car
run in the morning we would go out
uh this dude this kid that uh uh i grew
up around and we would get in people's
cars and move them
so if you're you were warming up your
car in your driveway you moved down we
would get it we would move it and switch
it with your neighbor's car so you'd
come out and there would be a car
warming up in your driveway it just
wasn't yours it's hilarious
but the kids in my hair would just steal
the car
so because i remember there was like uh
i think pioneer made it where you could
click a button because
it'd be freezing like a blizzard yeah
and you'd be in the house you could just
start your car so when the time you got
in everything was defrosted is warm
which you take like half an hour to warm
up but you can just press a button
well that word got around town and
people were just jacking cars
it was the worst way to wake up dude the
scraping the windshield
i remember the i remember vividly the
last time i scraped the windshield i
said to my dad i put it down
and i said hey i'm never doing that
again the worst and he said i'm
i'm gonna be living in cold weather for
a long time i go yeah but i'm
i'm i'll never be back it's not sports
aren't fun sledding's all right
skiing snowboarding overrated tell me
how much it sucks to be walking in your
kicks
and to step in one of those slush
puddles i know it was [ __ ]
yeah over dude no i like the fashion in
winter like coats but if it's too big
then you take it off you're sweaty
inside the air the other thing is you
know how you can tell it's too cold
here's how here's how i can tell you
right now i'm never living in your city
if i don't know my nose is running until
i taste it oh dude it's too [ __ ]
it's just too numb it's just numb if it
rolls down you're like
dude so but you guys went to nashville
and you loved it went to nashville man
we really really loved it and um
you know the truth is and i'm sure
you're going through this
also did you ever think you were going
to leave
l.a never so it's that's what it is for
me when
for me it's not nervous starting there
and i'm i actually that newness excites
me me too it gets my creative juices
going
but as lifewise as a person i
i just always saw myself here do you
know insulin the worst anxiety yeah
yeah yeah and i'm also worried about and
it's one of the current events is jerry
seinfeld was talking about new york
because
this this blogger wrote how new york's
dead and jerry goes in on
him and i stand by everything jerry said
and he talks about how
you know there's a creativeness and
there's energy with new york and l.a and
tokyo and london and
i'm worried that that creativeness and
that energy
might be lost if you go you know like i
was talking tim dylan about
moving to austin i'm like dude let's go
out there and start a show
podcast studios and stuff and he goes
maybe because my my worry is it feels
like i'm actually moving into retirement
because it feels a little bit like
retirement if we move out there
which i understand a hundred percent i
you know one of the reasons that like
when our kid my kids we were empty
nesters and we were still stuck out in
encino
i said to beth i'm like what the [ __ ] we
got to get out
down into the energy because i'm
becoming complacent out here
i'm just i'm just sitting in my house
you know i'm just sitting here like
where's the
you're the first person and i and i'm
sure other people feel this way but
you're the first person to put it
the same way i've been putting with
putting it which is that energy that you
can't
see it but you feel it you feel it as
soon as you touch down that lady can
feel it yeah you're ready and so i will
say that it's scary right that's the
thing that scares me the most did you
feel it in nashville though there's a
bit of a buzz in nashville but so we're
not going to
move out to franklin or any of those
places out there
which is outside the city which is where
families are beth and i are
we're not going to be downtown and i
don't want to say exactly where we're
going to be
but we're going to be in the mix a
little bit because that's what we want
we want that energy we want to be
where people are walking around we want
to be where someone can walk
to get their [ __ ] their groceries where
their people just moving all the time
you know what i mean see what i want oh
i kind of have it here where
i live far from the city so my home life
it's safe
there's yards there's kids can play
there's wide open areas but then i drive
in into the end
yeah energy and the the vibe of a big
city and then i can get out
because i don't want my family living in
the energy i'm i'm with you that man but
my kids are all i know you're good
you're grown so
that's the thing theo's going to
nashville just for the month of
september just to feel it out
and he's just waiting to see what
everyone does what do you feel like for
you
is that your biggest fear is what will
happen creatively and outside of that
you're not scared
like you're good with all of it scares
me yeah
all that scares me yeah i think you know
it's like the
you know the bands breaking up man by
band i mean all of us
yeah you know well freaking joey's
always
already in new jersey i'm a texas
morning joey's in new jersey
um you know other guys
aren't working for other reasons right
we won't get into
brogan is in texas uh do you feel like
though to me it's just like
you know one thing that keep keeps me
here in la is like my friends my
that and even if we might have saw each
other all the time but we
would work with each other and see each
other at the store or the improv or
wherever
it's just like now that that's kind of
gone it's like i don't know man
here's here's the thing that i'm excited
about because
i am the type of person though where
something new and scary excites me
me too and i am the type of person that
needs that every now and then
i need to be like i don't know let's not
open the shoot for a while let's see
what the [ __ ] happens
me too i do better when i'm like i need
to figure this out me too it always
works out better for me
i'm like [ __ ] when i'm a little scared
i'm like i don't know man
then i dialed down because right now
it's
you know my stuff in la's pretty set
like i know you know obviously there's
shenanigans
firing the kid right but outside that
everything's pretty
i might have a schedule it's like
there's not too much unknown
uh here's the one thing i will say that
i'm excited about and for you guys who
are moving to austin also
so comedy in la got as
good as it could possibly get
like best ever without a doubt man
if you if you combine the talent that
was here
like the amount of when i when i would
go on the road i'm sure you too and you
would look at who was at the club before
you and who's after you always do you're
just like killer killer
kayla's dude killer killer killer every
club i'm like well you guys got three
months of
just monster heat yeah right so
what was happening here was bound to we
we all talked about it i'm sure you did
when's the bubble gonna burst when the
bubble went right
i think what's exciting is so
it got as good as it got and now let's
see what's next
yeah it's almost like i don't think it's
here though i don't either not right now
i don't either i think some of the
smaller places i don't i don't i don't
think so either i don't know
look when when um if you look at the
comedy store and we both love the comedy
store and the comedy store man
mitzi passed me i worked the door at the
comedy store i didn't know you were a
door guy i worked the tour of the comedy
store what
yeah dude mitzi who were you a door guy
with anyone else that made it
ah because for every door guy that's
made it there's way more that dinner yes
it was like i was a door gunner but
you're also a bouncer at a nightclub
like dude just because you're a door guy
doesn't give you any credit into the
like you know what mitzi said to me the
first time she catches me up coming off
stage and she
gave me the you get the bony finger
that sounds dirty but it is yeah but
she's calling you over and i sat down
next to her and she said um
you were very funny and i said thank you
and she goes you're so handsome like a
young steve
guttenberg stephen
all right well and i was like all right
it's a weird reference but uh
jesus christ
you're way better looking than that guy
i was like god i appreciate you liking
the set
but i'll take offense the gutenberg rep
i will say this as a jew
the one thing that happens to jews is
that looking see young steve guttenberg
he doesn't look so jewy but one day jews
just look like jews they're like
cinderella like
one day your cheeks sag one day you're
like this young handsome dude and the
next day
agents too though you're a [ __ ]
asians are gorgeous to
like 79 even a hundred and then
overnight it's like
holy [ __ ] dude well listen man if you go
to 100 is it really overnight i mean you
you know what i'm saying even asians at
100 like you're like god damn and then
whatever father time's like nah man
time's up what if you had to have sex
with an
over 80 woman ooh has it got to be a
asian yeah
asian or black i think black yeah
definitely not white no
as a white guy i'm here to let you know
man
white people age like fruit yeah it's
all bones and
although white guys don't age bad like
there's some handsome older white dudes
yeah but i will say this about white
dudes you never
see a white dude over say 70
who's over 150 pounds 175 that's my
thing dude
name the biggest grandpa you know i
don't have a lot of time left no i need
to make some moves here
i'm saying like that's what i'm saying
name the biggest grandpa you know
with tattoos and cauliflower ears i'll
wait yeah
i got 20 good years left man you got to
make them count well listen dude you
keep getting out on that bike man
still still name a tall grandpa
they're just it's game over no you're
right we're like great danes
dude you know what happened to okay i'm
sure this has happened to you
i'm in the airport at nat in nashville
have you ever been up
straddled up to a urinal and like an old
dude straddles up next to you and he
really has trouble peeing and he makes
those pee noises
like it you can tell it's a struggle
city yeah where first of all to drip
it's a it's a there's a lot of this
but inevitably that dude lets out like a
40-second
part he's been like you know what i mean
like the one long continuous
but isn't it weird like that's the only
place where it's okay just to let it rip
and no one's gonna say anything i still
laugh at 37 i still laugh
like i'll have to go wait and laugh come
on man the urinal is the only place
where it's just like
but you don't laugh the first 15 seconds
but you're like is this still
is this i just tried to zone out it's
very weird it's just a
yeah you can tell he's just been dude
he's he's in his sweats
yep for sure in the pocket making the uh
it's a struggle dude i will say also
and i was telling you this all fair man
i have finally
reached that age where i think i always
have to wear underwear
and i don't think i can wear khakis
anymore
but khakis with the undies well no cause
there's a drip
and that is just i know that one i'm
sure ranks has a drip
i'm sure you when you go to the bathroom
and he goes to the bathroom
at your age you can still say i'm going
to take quick pee oh yeah there's no
such thing for ranks there's no quick
pee
and brian has the biggest balls you've
ever seen in your life big or long
ball they're like well they're like
they're just old they're like they're
like low hanging
and i'm like dude you need a you don't
have some people get like a face lift
you need a nut lift
and and also some [ __ ] some some
botox
they're so wrinkly well i don't mind
wrinkly nuts i don't think you're nuts
you've never seen you've never seen nuts
like brian you're t are you if you have
wrinkly nuts you taking a little needle
into your nut just for cosmetics i'm not
yeah but some guys do they smooth like a
basketball i [ __ ] that that's not that
important
i think it's more in the gay community
let me ask you a question how
come and now you're bringing it up
plastic surgeons you can get your boobs
lifted without getting fake boobs
how come we can't get like a little
fishing reel you know what i mean so you
can
it's like i'm pretty sure they do a
thing it's called a ball tuck but what
if you wanted it to be like
blinds so you could you know lift them
up and drop them well your body
naturally does that with temperature
right
actually you're not a certain age yeah i
don't know brian's there you go
holy thousands of parents catch men have
tried scroll talks just not models
by the way the ones on the right
ordinary terrible like teachers
fathers business people that's also from
the 80s
but let me ask you a question are you
would you rather have the left by the
way those nuts are terr
those are the worst nuts either ones but
you would rather be right nut like those
look like
alien pops yeah i'd rather be the left
not i i don't want shots
like those might be mine those are
identical to my nuts
those ones on the right look so
disturbing those aren't good those look
like a alien like i don't like
they're so shiny yeah and why i don't
want smoke look what the guy says i can
see my reflection in him first of all
oh how about this cubby the professor
yeah that's why you say cubby the
professional bodybuilder
my scrum looks like a christmas ornament
i don't want that dude
but i i do like the name scrotox
i think like the name cubby i don't not
for a bodybuilder no
i don't like that name oh yeah that's a
hard pass i wouldn't do it the the
the the needle to the nuts as well and
now there's any girl been like oh you're
nuts are stupid
i'm sure really i'm sure don't you think
there's i don't like
you're not just too wrinkly well said no
one ever
i don't i don't i don't wax my nuts
no i know i know dudes who wax their
nuts they have
that their nuts are that hairy they got
a wax that's what i said i said how
hairy
how how hairy how hairy they don't have
a lot of
follicles on there was one guy who told
me that he was like yeah
i waxed everything i waxed my taint and
i was like dude if you have hair on your
taint
you've got an extra chromosome yeah you
shouldn't have that should be or you're
russian
yeah but that should be a hair free yeah
zone that's a tank
dude you know that's why thank god at
manscape
you know they've been watching the show
but where they don't nick your nuts like
before i would use my same face right
like thing
do you nick your nuts dude they first of
all they bleed
oh i don't know forever the first time
you nick your nuts
you're like oh i'm bleeding out is this
how it ends you're gonna die oh yeah i
called my dad
i'm like what what am i supposed to do
he was like yeah it's just kind of like
for
if you're trying to get rid of yourself
forget cutting your wrist cut your nuts
yeah the blood it just flows if you and
it's like
it's like a paper clip and it's i'm
telling you
you're you'll bleed through your
underwear yeah forever every guy ever
yeah
then manscape was like we need this to
stop yeah this
is i remember the first time i cut my
nuts
i was worried i was like this is not
what do you do this is i put my feet
above my heart i'm like i gotta stop
smart
i gotta stop the bleeding i just like
well that's how i go that's how i go oh
dude i [ __ ] i was riding my bike
yesterday
and i was going down this hard decline
uh flying probably 40 miles an hour
[ __ ] flying
but i'm using the brakes so i don't want
to crash and so i'm using the brakes
using brakes
and i go to yeah there i am i don't be
mad at the quads i go to get off
dude the the brake i wouldn't think
about it because when you're braking
it's going to get hot and i got off and
like
just wanted to set my bike because i was
going to get something out of my bag
the brake like caliber hit my leg
dude i thought i swear to god i thought
a rattlesnake finally got me
it was the break was steaming i mean
really piping hot
burn singed the [ __ ] on my list but i
swear to god i was like oh
it's a rattlesnake it hurt that bad
around i literally screamed out
it hurt so bad are you a
high-pitched screamer or are you like a
man
who are you [ __ ] yeah i'm that guy right
away
i am a unfortunate screamer hi my
brother won't see
horror movies with me not only am i a
shrieker dude i'm gonna tell you a
little
bit a bit of a [ __ ] move i'm a jazz
hander i'll meet you
yeah yeah i'll do it yeah
is it weird the jazz hand
yes my jacob my son
knows that i scream like a [ __ ] when i
get scared so he
scared me a bunch of times over the
years and i didn't know what he was he
he put a video together and it's just
like
30 scares of me going [ __ ] you
like that the whole thing what a dick
dude last time i was watching the other
thing is
hot house on haunted hill i think that
wasn't that that scary netflix
show it's so good part two is coming in
october part two uh
2020 october but uh house on i know on
that that was a video game
the the house on notting hill something
like that i think that's right
but there's a scene in there spoiler in
three two
one there's a scene in there towards the
end where
they're just they're taught like it's a
ghost that haunts them right and they're
just talking the car and you like
you know when there's like the music or
there's a build up yeah like something
scary so you kind of brace yourself
and we're just what me and my girl's
sitting there watching the couch and i
get my arm around her
and i'm like yes this [ __ ] is kind of
boring like it was good
and then something pops out out of where
you didn't expect
dude i [ __ ] did like this i brought
my leg up like this
i was like yeah my girl's like
oh my god i was so embarrassed what is
what is the type of haunted movie
because saw and movies like that they
don't the gore
they don't scare me they don't scare me
like hostile scares me hustle too scares
me because that probably really goes
anything that i think could possibly
even a one percent chance of scaring the
[ __ ] out of me
like annabelle the conjuring oh dude any
demon
stuff you gotta watch this netflix here
really oh dude is it if you like scary
yeah
it's like that yeah it's this this house
that these kids grew up in it's haunted
but never really leaves them it's so
good what was that movie
yeah where the people showed up i think
it was based on a true story
where those people showed up at a house
some people were renting in masks
oh i know what you're talking about
strangers was it called the strangers
oh no strangers i think you're right i
think strangers you like scary movies
stuff too cat yeah
yeah i love it that movie anything where
it could happen really that's it
yeah that was [ __ ] scary anything
where it could happen like even the
first purge is a little scary dude
that could definitely ha we're kind of
moving that way what's your move on the
purge
if you have 24 hours what's your move uh
rent a boat and get out get out
i'm gonna run as soon as like hey purge
in three months i'm going to marina del
rey
paying whatever it takes to rent a boat
for the next five months
i'm going out there yeah i'm not i'm not
i'm not pretending to be tough guy
no there's no that's not like movement
mm-hmm i'm not
i'm getting a boat we're out of here
yeah yeah but whatever city's not doing
it fly me there
listen dude you're talking two guys one
guy who matches his kerchief to his
shirt yeah dude
i don't wanna i don't partake in any of
it and another dude
can you imagine killing like even my
worst enemy what no
no i can't even kill animals like like
my i'll teach my son not to
like his grandma that there's ants
there's time to step on him and then
we're outside
yesterday and he's like papa answered
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
we don't kill ants dude dude he's like
why i'm like we don't kill anything
we kill nothing do you like no spiders i
catch i release
really unless there's like a rattlesnake
in the house
but even i catch fires i release them i
don't step on ants
i don't hit bees outdoors this is your
territory outdoors
you're outdoors i'm not going to kill
you unless it's one of those wasps with
abs
done if it's one of those fornates this
brian calls him
abs and it won't leave your family alone
well then i gotta end it dude
because now you're a threat to the fan
but when it when a when a bee
buzzes your tower are you calm cool and
collected nope
terrified of bees me too what's that one
of those well if one of those hornates
decides to come around the family
i'm gonna have to execute you buddy why
does that dude's thumb look at the size
of his thumb
that's a big ass [ __ ] good god
how how about my father-in-law was
trying to be cool around my son where by
the pool for the reason
there's you know bees do their thing i
don't know if they're drinking water or
whatever but they're like floating
around
and he's like yeah they're harmless they
weren't doing anything and one was like
zoom around
my son's let my son scare him because
i'm scared of him so he's like oh let's
be scared
so his grandpa my father-in-law was like
no don't you have to worry about seeing
he's like you catch him throw him and he
goes look ah
the thing bit the stung the [ __ ] out i'm
like dude what
are you thinking dude what the [ __ ] you
thinking i'm interested man
i i don't know if i've ever asked you
this before eight inches
but i'm i've definitely never asked you
that are you talking about the length of
your foot
yep i'm sorry um brian's ball's back
yeah
they're so big i wish we could show them
they're something i i mean i'm not i'd
take a look once probably not the best
thing to show right now but
yeah probably hard pass um i'm super
curious i ask
parents this all the time because i i'm
curious if they're
related what's the one thing that you
wish your kids get from you and what's
the one thing you wish that they
don't get from you you good lord
what a question and are because for a
lot of people they i when i ask that
they're kind of related i've never
thought about that
so i hope they they'll go ahead well no
go ahead because i ask you yeah
well the one thing he takes from me yeah
what if one thing you work ethic
like whatever i don't give a [ __ ] what
he does whether it's video games
whether he gets into stand-up tv any
sport as long as he works his ass off
right i'll support any of it yeah but if
he's half asset i'm gonna be so
disappointed
just work ethic seeing how hard i work
the one thing i hope he doesn't get from
me is probably don't work all the time
so they're they're stories all the time
and then also maybe i i don't know
i i probably should talk to someone
about with material things like i'm i'm
really into cars i'm really into shoes
uh houses like real estate i hope he's
not that into the stuff
but if he grows up with me like these
she's like but he sees
he's like papa those are big bird i'm
like they're not dude they're grateful
deads know your [ __ ]
you know but it's like i hope he doesn't
well listen dude like he grew up
differently than you you grew up with no
money right yeah and that was like the
way to be cool right
in school was like shoes and like
clothes like made it cool
i don't know it's interesting dude
because it that
they the two relate yeah and my two
relate too like i
always wanted my kids to
to be good to people i want to look
people in the eye
to treat people with respect like how
you treat other people to me
is a sign of who you are as a person
don't you think they'll get that though
because
if you let's say you're not let's say
you're an [ __ ] and you're racist
there's a good chance your kids gonna be
racist that's where it stands like
racism yeah we're not born with racism
no comes from shitty parenting but
sometimes you can look at it
you know sometimes you rebel against
your parents and sometimes you're on
board with it
do you know what i mean like so for me
like i wanted them to just
know that the way you treat other people
is a reflection of the type of person
you are
in my mind especially the way you treat
people
who you don't have to treat well correct
people that can't help you yeah i think
that haters
and whoever it is a hundred percent
shows me who you
are yes but the one thing i hope they
don't get from
me which has happened to me here in los
angeles
and is one of the reasons you know one
of the good things about moving dude
is that the things about yourself that
you don't love
you're going into a new place where you
get to start fresh
you think listen because i feel like
you're meeting new people
yeah you if there are one or two things
that you about yourself that you want to
go you know what
this needs an update you can do that
around
a new group of people like not you're
not gonna turn into like a brand new
people are like that's
[ __ ] yeah like but like for me josh
raps now
yeah yeah for me the one thing that
i hope doesn't happen to them that has
happened
is i don't want their that treating
people well to be
i don't want them to become weak with it
does that make sense yeah where people
take advantage of them yeah yeah
yeah and so i i found myself
that happening to me for a few years
here
you're so nice it was just people saw
that you're like the number nuggets
of comics exactly where you don't have
that killer instinct
right you you need kobe on your team you
need you need a you need a killer you
need someone who's like 140 step on the
gas yeah
and it also if you're gonna you know
push this player this guy's coming and
he's gonna beat the [ __ ]
100 100 and so it's weird how the two
are combined but your two are combined i
know
oh that is strange because it is
probably
your one of your huge strengths is your
work ethic
yes but do you have balance i haven't
for a long time
i found balance in this pandemic do you
think
when you're out of the pandemic those
lessons will be
will stick i think so yeah because
because my son you know he's only nine
months
i've been so hands on put him to bed
waking them up spend their day with you
know i've been so hands on as a dad
like there's like it's like doing four
weekends in a month isn't
that's not no matter how much money i
make it's not worth it
yeah because like i miss a lot of stuff
with my oldest son you know
my girl's like yeah i got all this with
tiger like you missed a lot of this
because
i had to because i you know i was in
touring dublin australia because i was
going to get my foot in the door so
i had to do at the time so now it's a
little different it's funny too
when you the things when i would tell
look at those
the things when i would tell like uh
the things where i would tell beth i
can't miss this weekend she was like
well how about next weekend
i can't miss next weekend and now that
there are no weekends you realize
none of those weekends are important i
know not a [ __ ] one of them
are as imp you could miss any of them
you could miss
absolutely any of them for me
i mean obviously i wish this pandemic
hadn't gone down or whatever we want to
call it
you take some positives out of it there
have been i i can wear the scarf without
being judged for the rest of my life i
mean you were judged when you walked in
here but still i can still wear it
repeat like if i walked in another place
like get out of here now there's like
maybe sick i all right matches whatever
yeah i mean i
just wear this i'm gonna wear this at
21. say that right now are you rocking
oh this just
this is my thing down dude welcome to
scarf city baby
when are you gonna start wearing one
around your wrist oh my gosh yeah
unless you play guitar you can't wait
around the wrist
dude i've seen someone do that forever
and i tell you so back when
you remember when those thick leather
cuffs oh yeah okay
so we had a fake lever cut leather cuff
and i was playing baton rouge louisiana
and i walk into this club and uh the
guy's like all right and i've never been
there before he goes okay and we go over
the whole thing
and he said to me he goes but uh look
man um and what do you need for sound i
told him he goes what's the setup and i
told him
he goes listen we don't have a setup for
a bird and i go what
and he goes he goes we we can't we i
mean your bird can't come i'm like
what are you talking about he goes isn't
that for a bird i'm like oh no
it's not it's not a bird it's like yeah
dude to rock them now we said it before
like with brad pitt
you can wear whatever you want well this
dude dude even like the bracelet
it's like i'm sure maybe one of his kids
gave to him but if i just came into rock
and i'd be like dude come on man can you
go back to what the title this is called
johnny depp's style leather oh so he
doesn't
this isn't his that's not just this is
probably gucci or some [ __ ] like that
i gotta tell you man i barely he looks
showered in that picture so i'm alarmed
by that yeah
this johnny depp looks like there you go
it's still good looking he looks dope
like that
but he's cool he smells he looks like he
smells like old meat yeah
like he sounds like a pirate yeah yeah
yeah he's got a lot um
but going back to nashville like i think
whether it's nashville texas
phoenix vegas it's different too if this
was you know in the 90s or 80s like when
you're gone
it you're [ __ ] gone now it's like
with
connecting internet connect podcasts
social media it's like
you're still connected you know a
hundred percent you're not just off the
map
and if you you can stop your boys on
your show they can fly there
they can zoom like it's not like just
josh is gone you know we're never gonna
hear from you like you can still be in
the same
orbit you had to be in
la or new york before and now that's
just not the case
it's just not the case and that's what
makes it less scary
it makes it like okay this is kind of
like
look we're not we're not pioneers we're
not going into cities that don't have
buildings
you know what i mean but we are going
into a place that doesn't exactly have
what we do
so there is a huge unknown but the end
of the day
how many of the people who listen to
this show are in los angeles
yeah yeah yeah i know
what i mean like so if i think about the
money
that i actually make because i'm here
agree there's more pros than cons
especially the way this
the especially the way this state's
headed dude i would
if i'm you with two young kids i would
love to raise them somewhere
no offense to the other parents where
you live in richie ridgeville but
i think i loved my kids growing up with
a little diversity
and a little roughness not rough like
danger but like
yes do you know the name yeah with a
little bit because
like dude even here we went on a tour of
other schools that he would go to from
you know kindergarten through sixth
grade and we're going around the schools
i'm like jesus christ man
jesus christ what do you looks like a
goddamn apple
building it's like there's gonna be no
obstacles there's just
how many benefits did you get out of
growing up poor
but but even but and not only that but
growing up around so many different
people yeah
navigate my way through right just get
this kid's super hostile this kid's this
like
you don't want it all to be a smooth
ride as much as i don't want to deal
with turmoil it's like you kind of gotta
man
i think and also if you look at the
public schools especially that lake
travis
in certain public schools in austin
those public school systems some of the
best in the nation
because of barbara bush who was a former
teacher put all this funding into the
schools
so schools are through the [ __ ] roof
like there's something with that that i
dig
i and i am a i i'm a firm believer in
public schools man like i'm in la i'm
not exactly
i do want my kid to survive yeah like
there is you know
you want to have a bit of a rough time
but you also want to stay alive you but
you
yes but you want to go to a school and
be like you don't want him growing up
being like everybody's rich and white
correct because we know those people
i've never enjoyed any of them
not a [ __ ] one of them not a [ __ ]
one of them so
i think it's really important man i
think you're doing the right thing
especially
for schools and by the way you know
what's going to be here in five years
california
that's what i saw my father-in-law
yesterday because he's gonna retire he's
gonna come with us and
you know they don't tax his 401k out
there stuff like that
and uh you know i was like i just have i
get horrible anxiety when i think about
like i love my house picture picking all
the stuff up and leaving the kids and
stuff like that
and he was brendan at the end of the day
let's say worst case scenario you go out
there
and you hate it what you're not but
let's say you [ __ ] hate it
you know they still here man you know
he's come back a year or two later like
it's not
for you're not going to another country
yeah you just come back
and dude you'll come back with a renewed
uh
you know my thing is i'm not gonna just
move to like like travis and just be
gone forever
right like i'm still gonna have to fly
back probably weekly to start
to la me too commute i i mean i already
i told beth i'm like i'm probably gonna
have to fly back
because but all your all your kids are
gonna still be here right
my kids are here my brothers are all
here all three of my brothers live here
um you know my parents live in reno and
i but i told my parents i said
if if i was a like my parents are in
their 80s
so they're taking zero risk and i don't
blame them they're like hey we
don't want to travel they don't travel
my dad hasn't left his house since
my dad too cnn ran one article look my
dad's
my dad and mom are both over 80. so as
healthy and my dad
goes he does golf every day does have
your genetics my dad has
had a six-pack at 65 years old your
dad's straight yeah he's fine he's
he's good this dude but they don't want
to leave
they don't take a chance but i get that
i totally get it so he told
my mom and dad both were like look if
you go to nashville and you're worried
about not seeing us
you're not going to see us till spring
anyway it doesn't matter
dude my dad i told my dad like you guys
i sent a picture of boss he's like jesus
christ he's getting big
i sent him a video of tiger singing
because tiger loves music right now
so i sent him a video that is he singing
uh meet me in the middle
yeah yeah he loves drake he loves drake
all right
but so i tell my dad a bit and he's like
god i miss him he's like
we're going to come out there i'm like
oh yeah the flights are cheap i'll book
your tickets like
chill nobody's flying yeah we'll drive
out there like god damn
from colorado yeah he's like we'll just
drive nonstop as he just got i don't
know
dude we just go on road trips as a kid
but that's he's like we're not dealing
with covet at all like all right
do you know when we used to drive my dad
my
mom and dad both terrible farters
oh they're far in the car and so
there was one time we were driving on
the mass turnpike which is the big
turnpike in massachusetts
and um my dad pulled the car over
because my mom was just
she must have been on like a heavy
protein diet or something just ripping
it up
just and my dad pulls the car would you
guys laugh at it
it was rough we were laughing but it was
rough and my dad pulled the car over
and we're on the side of the freeway and
he goes hey you got to step out
yeah you [ __ ] and my mom goes what she
hears what do you want me to do he goes
i don't know walk it off but you got to
get out
you got to do something he's a long ride
man
because you know sometimes it gets stuck
in your pants he was just shaking
just get the [ __ ] out of the car so my
mom just walked up and down the freeway
for a little while on the side we sat in
the
you good all right let's get back to
jesus christ but also
tight moves but also tight moves yeah i
could never do what
do you go back to boston much well my
parents live in reno now
so for me no reason for it really i love
performing in boston what tweet is all
my good friends are from boston is that
right
oh every like good friend i have rogan
you jeff foley like stevie blue eyes
like i have so many friends from boston
listen man i i am going to be completely
biased
but i think there's something about the
northeast and i think it's something to
do with the pace
and how you're you grow up giving each
other [ __ ] it's a different style of
humor
yeah and there's a certain pace to it
that what club do you uh do when i go
back there i go to laugh boston
um is that a good club i've never been
there yeah man i i love
see i like there's something cool about
theaters right i think you do the real
term back there
i do the wilbur wheelbarrowman yeah
where i think theaters are cool
for other comics but as far as for the
fans go
the club is the best experience you can
have for comedy venues the club's by far
the best
theater's too big not personal the
energy you can't feel the energy
clubs are the way to do it so like
boston's one of my favorite [ __ ]
cities of all time
named my son boston for god's sakes so
it's like
i i hated last time i went there i did
the wilbur
one night and then i was out go to like
to me it's the experience of like
the city for three days i'm with my
brother and my openers and we're eating
at great places and
i have friends there but by the way you
could get you could get tickets up on
top of the green monster and go see a
game yeah go to the guards
you really get to experience the city
you know why and i
this is counterintuitive i know but i
was supposed to shoot my special in
march right
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah uh march 24th
well here's the thing so when we were
deciding
my agent was sending me all these
theaters and i go man i don't
i as long as we're shooting a special
where i
i want to be my best i'm way better in a
club than i am in a theater
i like the interaction you've been doing
long enough where you know
i know that my show
is at its best when it feels like a true
conversation
yes when there's a like i'll talk to
people in the crowd
and and we'll get through as bits and
like
but but but and people it's important
for me that the other people in the
crowd can hear them
that's part of the show and in the
theater that's harder i feel like i'm
better
also you know what the big stage makes
me do it makes me get
too big i i lose my sense of
conversation because i just feel like oh
i'm on this big stage
i have to be this big but just
personally yeah and you're like getting
the energy back the laughs are different
yeah but it's weird cause there's
theater acts and there's a reenact right
like what kevin hart does is
it's [ __ ] have you ever seen a show
like i was always like
how someone could pull off an arena like
what are we doing here dude
it's a it's a show dude it's like a
spectacle
like you've never seen but there's
nobody doing it like him well he's an
arena actor
there's certain arena acts and there's
certain theater acts
and then there's like guys just know
like clubs they're just you know i've
been coming for six minutes but
i would never shoot another special in a
theater again
i love the club and that's exactly by
the way i like the club better on t
that's ridiculous we we i i like the
club better on tv too
me too like like i know andrew schultz
is shooting at theater
and he knows more better than anybody
but i want andrew andrew schultz when he
comes out
dude he's lighting that audience up yeah
and we love it
love it and if you do a big theater
you're going to lose that i love
connection tim dillon and club
but but and that's the thing is that you
get that connection you know what else
you get
i love the energy of people on top of
each other
i love a low ceiling kind of
basement feel it is so different
but because we did look i used to tour
the cable guy
you know he sold 55 000 seats
you know i do you know what's
embarrassing i didn't realize how big he
was dude and i made a joke like
what's tom made or do like i forget
maybe to theo or
i forget maybe rogan what's tomater
doing and there was
like are you crazy you ever seen him
link it you played it you played
football
against nebraska right he sold out
nebraska's link to the show yeah i was
i did that show with him that that dude
but i feel like the medium of comedy's
not made for that i agree it's just not
i have a couple of now get your money
larry cable guy and
you're goddamn right dude i'm a huge fan
and my son [ __ ] loves tomato he has a
million stuffed toys
and i love tomato i just don't feel like
the medium is made for that
i agree with you and i will tell you
something about this dude he donated
every dollar he made from the gate to
charity at that show
every time it's because he has a billion
dollars being told mater i mean
he's probably doing all right but i let
me tell you by the way
one of the nicest men in comedy when i
hear other comics bash him
why would they bash him i'm like hey
do half of do you know we counted one
night punch lines in his set
369 punch lines here's the other thing
it's also an act this is how smart this
guy is come on
it's an act yeah have you ever looked up
blair the cable guy yeah before what's
his real name dan whitney
he was dan whit forever and would do
this as a freight train of comedy yeah
he would do this as an act and it was
getting big so he's like
oh i'm just going to be later the cable
guy it's all in that he told me
at some point he um he would do
dan whitney freight train of comedy and
then he would do larry the cable guy in
the middle of his act
but he was he would have a hard time
following larry the cable guy as dan
whitney so he could never
do it there he is and he would just
rattle off these jokes but
what's weird it's like certain guys get
caught in that persona
of their act right like that's an act
and they get caught
and they can never get out of it and
some of it it's trouble where
if they're this partier and there's this
raging you know alcoholic and loud on
stage well people want that all the time
dude
so then you won't talk about having
problems we can go through the comics
you've had millions of problems yeah
playing up that persona all the time
larry the cable guy
yeah so dude at this gig right
it was for a comedy central special so
and i
he was like when are we starting up he
goes well there's somebody parachuting
in dressed as me
how long does this whoo
that a cornhusker stadium show
it's gotta be feels like eight nine
years
uh and how did you get connected to them
you know we had the same manager
so i toured with him for many years oh
really so he would open up for him yeah
so ready for this we are he
we're backstage and i go you going up he
goes wait this dude's
he's parachuting in he's pretending to
be me so they're starting special
they're going to watch this guy
parachute and dressed as me
with my voice over the loudspeakers and
then he's going to run in from behind
the stage and i'm going to run up
awesome so he starts to parachute in
right
and then you hear we're all watching and
dan's doing his voiceover or whatever
maybe he pre-taped it i forget
and um then you some guy who's standing
backstage that goes
uh-oh this is mark i go what happened he
goes
that's just a huge gust of wind now the
guy who's parachuting is an
older guy this is his going to be his
final jump
he crashes what dude
so he crashes oh into these seats
oh now ready for this everybody come
running
everybody thinks it's larry the cable
guy oh no
no now here's the thing with the gig
tomato
we can't start until he runs over he
knows this
this is how well it's a football this is
happening
he has to run down as larry the cable
guy and he's an older guy
he broke his coccyx but he knows that
the show can't start until he runs so
look at him
and all the fans think it's like it's
larry the cable guy
so look at this dude look at this dude
old dude this is his last jump
ever and he's like i just got to make it
backstage
and he limped backstage and then just
[ __ ] lands down
it was crazy and then when he came out
that audience
because they thought he ate [ __ ] so then
after the show
dan and i used to do something called
air disaster
where before all of his shows at
arenas or at theaters he had all of this
like wigs and and um guitars and drum
set that we never plugged in
but we we would give the sound people
before the show
a full 10 to 12 song set list and we
would do
full on air guitar as a band in front of
an empty stadium oh interesting
it was crazy so much fun we played a set
as air disaster after the show in front
of 55
000 people hilarious somebody
called our manager after the show and
said hey we'd like to book air disaster
ear disaster how many songs do they know
they thought we were a real band
hilarious and the man our manager was
like they know every song they know all
of them
all every song they have a song they can
do they can plug it yeah but they tried
to book us and the only reason i think
we didn't get booked
is because the amount of money that they
were offering cable guy was like
come on boy did he does did he steal
tour
yeah man he tore some um he tore some
again and i worked with foxworthy 2 i
wrote
on um fifth grader oh wow did you talk
about
a legend and jeff fox man i heard he
literally has like a straight up
game of thrones castle in atlanta dude
if you google
comedy comedy albums of all time oh that
has to be
you might be a redneck i bet you between
cable guy the blue collar
album ron white and foxworthy i bet you
out of the top 20
they have at least nine it's 2014 though
blue collar number one that's 2014. but
2014.
okay foxworthy number one i know man
it's crazy right joe foxworthy
and three and three we're now doing the
damn thing adam sandler five
isn't butthead how dare you but that's
not stand up right jane cook
dan cook dan cook didn't cook jerky boys
weird al
weird this is this is not i wouldn't
call these comedy albums they're the
cable guys
the cable guy they're the cable guy
they're the cable guys
jesus christ i mean and ron's got to be
in there
there angval he was part of the blue
collar
get that blue so that's the solar comic
tour that's seven with blue collar
that's
eight with the fox worthy that's nine
out of twenty jesus christ
it's nine out of twenty dude and that's
back then when them boys were making
real money off
sales like album sales let me tell you
something else how great foxworthy was
and and i could be wrong but i don't
think i
am i'm pretty sure those first blue
collar tours
you know he was the only name i think he
split it evenly
amongst the four what about us jeff
foxworthy and
and and larry the cable guy whether you
like their comedy or not or their
politics or whatever
are two of the nicest down-to-earth
realest guys oh and ron white's great
too ron white is a [ __ ]
man yeah he's a [ __ ] hoot but like
this tour this blue collar comedy tour
all of them
except for maybe one right hang vault
that's the one you're thinking of
you know what i'm saying like the other
guy from nsync you know well you know
you're like steve kerr on the 95 bulls
you know it's like
yeah yeah you were there by the way
steve kerr on the 95 bulls who
in no way thought he was as good as
michael jordan let me just get a point
let's go ahead let me go ahead did you
get any feedback on you i thought it's
not not on that but did you get any
feedback
on uh the your daughter you know rehab i
do want to say something
sincerely to the people who please tell
me don't get haters
no man i will tell you how i got
it's super humbling man i got not
between 80 and 90 messages and not like
one line
like chunks oh wow of people
sharing their stories with me as either
from my daughter's point of view or from
my point of view
and sharing their stories and talking
about how much it helps to hear other
people talk about it
i i read listen i read all of them
i have replied to most and we'll get to
all of them wow
it was real when people share their
lives with you like that man
it was really humbling man so i was i
was
how about my dumbass i'm talking about
intervention i'm like you got to blame
the parents and they're like
hold on and i was like wait and then i
was like
oh sometimes it is sometimes it is but a
lot of times it's like life happens
yeah man you know like life happens i'll
see eric sharing his story like
i was so into it i don't know if you
know i don't look at comments or
views i don't know but to me it was i i
was
i was blown away by it man i was
fascinated by it i don't usually look at
comments either
i just saw so many thank you thank you
thank you thank you and i was like
huh this they can't be all
thank you for being a dick or whatever
yeah there were so many that i was it
was overwhelming man and like i said
when people reach out and share their
their stories like that it's so humbling
that
that they've chosen you do you know what
i mean that it was
it was so crazy and super powerful i
will say
um i got almost as many messages telling
me that
nobody thinks they're as good as mike
trap hilarious so just see
it was almost equal i was gonna send to
you and eric how about mike trout's uh
rookie baseball card is now tied for the
highest baseball
card ever it's like tied with whoever
commented probably what is it
cobb maybe i free it's one speaker no
it's one you know right when you see i'm
like i remember when i was collecting
cards like oh yeah that's like the holy
grail you know i do miss
did you collect cards oh dude i am me
too
but when you were collecting because
we're obviously you're younger than me
were people buying the whole sets you
know what i mean that ruined
to me what ruined collecting cards is
now you can just buy the set
you can go online and go i want the
complete set from 19 from oh no i wanted
to collect that i'd buy the patent and
there's nothing better than opening a
pack oh
that smell of that gum oh like i there
it is
how much is it ernie banks is that right
ernie uh nope
look at this mike trout graded beckett
green card salesforce three point nine
million dollars
what yep yeah so hey foreign
somebody sent me that some one of your
what one of the fans of the show
sent me that oh honest wagner that's
right like it's like black and white and
he's like
just playing baseball against all white
guys i gotta tell you man those old
baseball card poses
are though there's nothing how do you go
back to that come on dude i remember we
i collected uh nba nfl you collected nba
oh dude and i remember i'll never forget
this because me and my brother
competitive
my mom would let's pick out you know the
packs opened a pack it was
shaquille o'neal and christian
lightner's rookie year and they were
both the biggest and
if you got either one of their cards is
a big deal i remember my brother open
his up and i was like [ __ ] i didn't get
anything
oh my up and the first i see shaquille
o'neal i'm like oh
[ __ ] swiped again and i see christian
later i got the two like
diamonds of the year and my brother i go
uh
and i was a little brother and i was
like i got shaquille o'neal chris later
he goes
holy [ __ ] i remember that's the card i
got
that's his rookie yep i got that one
christian lightner this kind of brother
i am
but my brother is so sad seeing you
anything i go you can pick one you can
have one
that's a little brother move man yep and
then he beat me up yeah i was going to
tell you
as a little brother i recognize that
move
like you think they're going to like you
more yeah like give me your i was going
to take it in here yeah you're like
take both of you [ __ ] so chris leighton
are only worth 30 bucks now
but the other one's worth what three
grand shaquille o'neal
well shocked to you like to me i don't
know why people
don't talk more about
he was a freak i mean some
two off like run up and down the court
and his athletic
do you know the only thing that ever
bothered me about shaq his little dick
why
yes no no i'm serious there's no way
he's got a little dick that's what they
say
who little compared to his body see
that's what they say but
his oh his old girlfriend say he had a
little wee-wee let me ask you but that
sounds like bitter yeah you're right
that sounds like a bitter also might be
true
but little compared to his body because
still a foot is little compared to his
body but if you're
hooking up with shaquille o'neal you're
expecting the cracking down your throat
do you think do you think if you are a
large
tall black dude and you have a tiny dick
you disappoint people
oh nothing worse
[Applause]
dude nothing what do you think that's
the way nothing works you
because if you're a woman you're
probably like well i know like girl you
see that size 16 shoes yeah get it girl
and you go home
like like the thing like you like this
is the other thing have you ever heard
of shaquille o'neal having a giant dick
never i guess i just ass you do hear
scottie pippen
you do hear dennis rodman you do hear
the dress for the phoenix suns
is packing the biggest heat can i ask
you a question
sure why do i know this stuff yeah like
i've never heard any of that
there's a form there's a form okay
what's called the heat no i don't know
and i just started that four
i just started the heat dude it's just
pro ballers with dicks out yeah it's
called the heat dude
did you imagine it just listed like nine
dudes you know what they say i'm like
whoo
like who's saying this i'm saying this
well your boy your boyfriend your boy
for the phoenix
john jackson so everybody
uh your boy uh for the phoenix sun
is dating
apparently devin booker has just oh did
you oh
we know juicy did you hear about that
girl
saying she sucked off seven of the
phoenix suns yup and it is such a turn
on
is it i was like oh damn that's cool
would you be eight
oh if i'm single i'm on the team a hundo
percent
if i'm coming eight a i'm not a starter
so i'm just lucky to get what i can get
okay
you know what i'm saying if you're if
you're six seven eight you ain't playing
really
but you think she went down the line up
like yeah
well she said uh homeboy was first oh
devin
yep look at those oh at the same time
wait no wonder they had such a good run
in the bubble wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait was at the same time
memorial day weekend here's one thing
i've never been into
listen man it's a crazy world we all
gotta adapt and people are buying more
stuff
online than ever before if you're an
e-commerce
seller or ready to meet the demands of
our new delivery culture be ready
with ship station why ship station
when you're selling online get a lot of
orders out fast can be super tough
listen we use it for all our merch a lot
of stuff
we've used them in the past they've
always been great that's why you guys
need ship
station it's how you keep track of who
gets what shipping cares
uh what should you use it gets you the
best rates all at shipstation.com
fastest easiest most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
just a few clicks and you'll be managing
your orders printing out labels getting
your products to happy customers
ship station makes it easy shipstation
helps online sellers of any size get
orders out quickly
save money on shipping costs and keep
customers happy no matter where you're
selling amazon
etsy your own website shipstation brings
you all your orders in one simple
interface
making them really easy to manage from
any device even your
freaking cell phone ship station works
with all the major carriers including
usps fedex
ups even amazon so you can compare and
choose the best shipping solution for
you
and your customer all right no
wondership station is the number one
choice of online sellers
you ship more and less time with the
best rates available and right now fire
and kid listeners can try
ship station faux free for 60 days when
use the code
fighter make sure your business is ready
to meet the demands of
delivery culture get started
shipstation.com today
click on the microphone at top of the
homepage and type in fighter that's
shipstation.com enter the code fighter
shipstation.com
make ship happen listen man my undies
want you guys to talk about your
underwear like seriously they have a lot
of feelings about it and want to chat
with anyone who will listen
so here it goes meundies just wants
everyone to feel comfy as heck
with the freedom to express themselves
that's why they make the world's softest
undies
in the world fun colors prints like dino
surfboards i just got my dinos one my
kid won't leave them alone
whatever you put on every day they want
you to be comfortable they want you to
be
you man meundies is serious about
softness
no like super serious they scoured the
world for the softest fabric
known to man it all starts with a
sustainable source
beechwood trees that magically turn from
pulp to yarn to undies
undies that kind of feel like heaven on
your skin for comfort from outside
literally to in all right keep your
underwear drawer
stocked with meundies membership a
subscription every month new pairs are
shipped right to your door plus get
site-wide savings exclusive sales
me undies has a great offer for you guys
first-time purchasers you get
15 off and free shipping this is a
no-brainer especially because they have
100
satisfaction guaranteed these are the
only underwear i rock
so join the club man they're the softest
in the world they got cool prints
matching with your girl
whatever you want to do i don't suggest
matching but they have that
option all right to get 15 of your first
order free shipping
100 satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com fighter
that's meundies.com fighter can we play
this yeah okay let me hear this
birthday i've seen them all at dre's
like this one team
okay she's so shy it's just so cute
seven seven basketball players in a row
mm-hmm
how was that i was [ __ ] up i didn't
[ __ ] any of them though she's done it
what happened
all of them yeah that happened you
didn't have like a weird reaction in
your stomach or anything no
no that sounds so fun you're almost
making it sound like you were too [ __ ]
up to be sucking seven dicks and also
you were getting [ __ ] by somebody else
right before this yeah they walked in
mid me getting [ __ ] how did they walk
in where were you
in the hotel room so i was [ __ ] like
someone that works with the team and i
know
i know that team because i've hooked up
with them before but they all pulled up
no not the whole team
yeah he's loading his gun right now what
this is what happened as a dad that
because that's plastered all over the
internet oh dude how many okay
let me i'm gonna tell you something i
guarantee you if you had a daughter
and that was your daughter i just want
you to know i would send you that video
once a day for a year oh dude i mean
just to [ __ ] with you
if i'm that dude if i'm that dad's
friend i'm sending him that video
once a day for look well she also has a
drake tattoo
okay but i am telling you right now
she's also really hot
i'm not into being in a room with seven
other dudes with my dick out
that's just not my thing i know
sounds terrible no like i like i get it
if that's your thing but that's not like
i wouldn't be like uh i'm out of here
boys
but what but here's the dude what are
you doing when she's sucking somebody
else's dick you're just talking to your
buddy
uh like that's the thing like oh that's
a lot that's a lot of weight so
like i've seen [ __ ] videos right yeah
those guys are just like in the corner
and you're like it's kind of lonely yeah
it seems just like depressing yeah i
don't know
that's the thing like i might be like
how long do you think you'll be i'll
come back
you know like i'm gonna go get some meat
you know what i'm gonna go
change and come right back listen i'm
gonna actually let you catch a shower
i'm in room 227. do you just want to get
done whatever you're doing here and then
stop by there i mean stop by and get
some mouthful that might be the most
that's what i'm saying i don't mind
depends are bonding as a team and they
played
so good in the bubble they played so
they were unstoppable
how about my celtics yeah i know they're
looking good the east is
whatever but do you think the celtics
have a chance to come out at least
uh no i think raptors are heat sorry
dude not the bucks
i see that anyway just make it from the
east the bucks could i
here's the thing with the bubble i don't
know who's going to win it maybe my
brother
balls deep in basketball right now it's
like with this bubble
you like there's no team we're like yep
that's it like i thought the lakers at
first and watched him like there's no
way
then you watch the clippers you're like
not really yeah you see and then you
see dallas you're like maybe if
porzingis gets healthy
then you watch three you watch houston
you're like [ __ ] dude
how about that three my man hit last
night oh uh dude
luca is luke is amazing here's what i i
think
i think and this is what i thought going
in and i i could
be proven wrong but like it's a
different type of mental toughness
basketball no in the bubble it's a it's
it's a different type of being able to
focus
like just about basketball like i think
kobe if if kobe had been in a bubble
you'd average 70 points
if you're telling me kobe bryant can
only eat sleep
drink basketball think about him or
jordan dude yeah again you're talking
about
those two mentalities but you know who
has the same mentality as those guys
damien lillard
yeah he's averaging what 40 points a
goddamn game so there's those guys that
just
you know like i think there's some
players yeah but there's also some
players that do it for the spectacle and
the fans stuff like that and they like
that admiration
there's some dudes who don't give a
flying [ __ ] it's just about beating you
and those guys are the ones who are like
goku like your boy you
hit that game-winning shot okay yeah
lucas balling like there's
damon lillard you look at these guys
they're just killers man
greek freak like you don't give a [ __ ] i
i i i look at the lakers i don't see it
they're just not tough there's there's
one thing that to me are gone off
where there's a transition and they were
walking and even
uh like the commentators like dude run
back on
like championship championship teams
don't walk yeah like they're gonna bust
their ass no matter what like
it shows literally the three superstars
walking as other teams down at the other
you're like what are you doing dude
i also think there are a lot of guys
because they're you know these are young
dudes who are millionaires that are
really famous [ __ ] a ton of girls
in the bubble they're not allowed
nobody's getting sucked off by this girl
in the bubble no she can't get into the
bubble and suck these boys off
so a lot of by the way smart gm would
have brought one girl in
trust me they're probably figuring it
out but i'm just saying it's like even
that it's not like
you know these these instagram thoughts
aren't getting bust in like usual so
it's like
a lot of these guys like dude this ain't
worth it i'll play next season
so i think a lot of you seem like
they're just checking out like just give
me the [ __ ] out of here
we don't have a chance to win anyways
get me out of here beat us in four so i
can get back in my dick suck that's what
the sixers did
yeah yeah six is right yeah we're good i
do i don't think
if you're the sixers you can come back
with simmons and embiid again i just
don't think it's not working is it
well but here's the thing about that
we're getting super deep on basketball
which i love but the fans are like okay
dude
okay no i love it butler was the
obviously the key to success butler was
the leading scorer
he butler is a killer butler is thriving
in the bubble butler is a
[ __ ] killer dealer he doesn't by the
way
and to me that's also like with this
lebron jordan
you like argument it's like i like
killers dude me kobe bryant [ __ ]
killer
uh you know michael jordan the biggest
[ __ ] yeah
then lebron he's a good dude but
lebron's doing what he thinks
you want him to do so when he's walking
in the arena carrying a malcolm x book
and he's only on the first page for the
last four games and someone goes
what was your favorite part of the book
he's all all of it
he's like what like you can tell like
that's not right you're not doing that
because you want to read the malcolm x
book
you're doing that because right now the
culture we live in and you feel
pressure to represent is he walking in
with the book i have not seen him
walking you know
he's walking with like a malcolm x book
but and then and then there
he knows they're filming back and he's
like laying down reading a book but it's
always on the same page basically
like however these days have you not
advanced in the book i mean listen like
he's just
doing it to like check that box like we
know you don't want to do that
the surefire to be to be fair if if i'm
having trouble sleeping
just hand me a book yeah i might be like
you're not a reader
i i do read but like i need to read
sitting up
if you catch me in bed it's gonna i'm
i'm a paragraph in and i'm it depends
what book it is sometimes
sometimes a book could be so good i
can't sleep which is weird i wasn't
always like that and like my son what
i'm trying to do with him is like
you don't have an ipad anymore but he
did for a while and he'd watch
it's crazy to me he would watch other
kids play with
toys like these kids would unbox toys
and he would watch that what's that
little asian kid's name who one boxes
[ __ ] hate that kid
right toys ryan's going to have a drug
problem i'll tell you that right now but
right isn't he making a gazillion
dollars a year the highest paid youtuber
for a long time and he has shown that
highest paid youtube the highest paid
yeah
oh my top 10 forbes earning uh
26 million how much of that money does
he get and how much do his parents get
together his parents take all of it yeah
because it's not hollywood there's no
the mcauley culkin rule
it's youtube so his parents are saying
thanks for the money little dude his
dad's all up in the video like suge
knight now
come on man dad all up in the video so
so so
he has his own tv show on nickelodeon
too but ryan doesn't get any of that
money i'm sure right yeah ryan's banking
at least half of that
22. because and there's no laws
if the kid and because i know here in in
walls
because it's not like the those laws
protect kids in hollywood yes uh
sag and stuff you've got kids youtube's
a wild free market
that is bananas man but i i i loan his
credit uh okay
to say he has his own line of toys just
my son gets something but my with my son
back to him in the
in the ipad she we took away from
because he would get home that's thing
you want i'm like dude you gotta go
outside and play play baseball or some
[ __ ] you can't watch youtube yeah
but he he would always go to other kids
playing
or doing something like why would you
want to watch kids
play i go smart smart kids don't do that
smart kids watch
you'll learn stuff about animals or yeah
about space or trucks like
watch stuff to educate yourself it's
crazy that you watch other kids play
i it's like twitch kids are watching
other kids playing video games
it's like you're mine but you know what
i asked jacob about him like why
because he he watches i'm like are you
watching somebody else play video games
he goes yeah i love it
because at such a high level he said i'm
i i'm
i i can't do that so i'm watching to
learn
how to do it and i like these guys this
is
i like they like their personalities
yeah there's a guy that my son
two guys that my son listens to one uh
watches one guy named castro
who's in texas who does a lot of fifa
who i his personality is [ __ ] great
and another guy named tim the tatman
interesting jacob watches them
religiously
interesting and loves it they upload
every day and play every day
every day but they're the amount of
there's so much content out there
god and you're thinking about it what
was that just found they're all like
niche
like i just had a nose hair fall out of
my nose
that is one of the most disturbing
things that's ever happened to me
a nose hair fell out of the mid-sentence
i don't know what to do like that i
think you just keep carrying on
but i don't know like that yeah that
happened are you can you lose hair in
your nose i thought you just
i don't know oh cluck knows his wrong
time like a gray or something do you
ever get one
where you pull on it and it closes your
eyes a little bit oh yeah it's like it's
attached to your eyelid and then and
then uh manscape sent me a nose trimmer
a weed whacker but it's like i don't
like the feeling of my
like my nose being trimmed like a fade
up there sometimes when you pull one it
feels like it's attached to your brain
oh dude you're like god am i dumber
but like back to the twitch and these
you like it's
to me it's like the the age of like
superstars like uh you know like a frank
sinatra's going old school like a frank
sinatra or
elvis or michael jacks or something like
that like the age of that though
those big stars like those megastars
worldwide known as
now it's all niche audiences great by
niche i mean like it can be a few
million or millions but
like that massive superstar doesn't
exist anymore because like the twitch
world i don't know a ton of guys
youtubers i don't know some of the main
guys but then i'll get introduced to
some of them i'm like
how many followers they have like 26
million like holy [ __ ]
i'm telling you the only you know the
only
exception i would tell you i think for
that rule is
boy bands anything that has to do with
people under the age of 18
who will all flock do you know what i
mean like bts one direction
things like that i think those still
have that kind of mania attached to it
where they walk down the street and
people are screaming and all that [ __ ]
but even that like my mom doesn't know
bts you know what i'm saying but like my
mom like
every kid knew michael jackson every mom
yeah michael jackson like that
i'm not global like there's no beatles
that's true but there's because there's
so you don't
have to listen to that one group anymore
there's so many things you can find
exactly what you
kind of like comedy too like anyone
who's selling out or has
an audience like that it's like a radio
station
it's not for everyone and you can change
station and you're going to find what
you dig
but that person they might have a huge
audience but you don't [ __ ] with it
so you flip the channel they have a huge
option you don't [ __ ] with you're gonna
find one
eventually it's what i love the most
about what we do dude
it's why i don't understand if somebody
watches something
and they send a comment and say i don't
like that there are
so many options why watch it
do you know what i mean like it's crazy
there's so many there's so you can find
exactly what you want now with stand-up
man it never offends me when someone
goes hey man i don't
yo i don't think you're funny it's so
subjective totally cool
but what i do love is that you're
watching comedy yes go find what you
like yep
because with the the the one thing that
i definitely have learned
over the past five years is that
somebody else or maybe even more
somebody else's success doesn't mean i
can't be successful too it has
nothing to do with zero to zero to do
with it as a matter of fact the more
people who like comedy
the better it is but also that mentality
of saying this person has this and i
don't you're never gonna get that agreed
you're never gonna get there ever agreed
i agree
it is a it's one of the reasons that i
am looking forward to leaving la
yeah i feel you because it takes that
the one thing la has done to me well not
too many i mean i let it happen
is that because there's so much opulence
and success
i'm always like well i gotta do more
you're around it i got in your constant
competing i gotta stay on the wheel i
stopped looking at youtube numbers a
long time ago
because i found myself being like all
right now oh man this person has this i
got to do this or i'm going to have to
book this guess
nope that's not i did you're going to
stress yourself out dude
this city makes you feel like you have
to be on the wheel comparing yourself
also especially especially when you're
around like
our group of like the group it's like
you know it shows and just
you're we're competitive by nature so
then you compare and everything it's
like dude
let me tell you it'll eat your life
it'll keep you up at night i remember
saying out loud once and i actually took
instagram off my phone for two weeks
after i said this out loud
he's got a bus oh with bert i was no
oh just some yeah i was i was like i
know he's got a bus
i've always wanted to be in a whole like
because i've always wanted
i toured with cable guy at a bus and it
seemed so cool i'm like i've always
wanted to be in it yeah
and then i was like i can't what am i
doing i know
what the [ __ ] am i doing but now but now
but
i see i've never been that way i'm like
ah [ __ ] that guy has that like i'll see
if i see whoever bert or you or anybody
like joe coy with a bus i'm like oh [ __ ]
man that'd be cool for me to get like to
me that's like oh that could be
something you could do down the road
dude maybe you'll get a bus there
there's something to you know look
forward to right but it's like
joe coy sent me a video today that he's
doing with jabbawockeez
and it's like i see that i'm like holy i
went dude you're taken to another level
man
so then i don't go off [ __ ] why didn't i
think of that i'm thinking
oh i need to do like i need to step my
game up but that's what i mean it keeps
you on the wheel
keeps you on the wheel keeps you up
there's a fine line but keep me on the
wheel and just being a [ __ ] hater
and if when you're a hater you're never
going to get that i agree i'm for sure
that
for me it plays into the thing that we
talked about earlier
which is i just got to keep going keep
going i wonder if i can show the joe coy
thing
you guys like the jabberwockies right my
uncle works with them what really what's
he do
uh he is the one who makes the beats for
their uh dancing
he's their producer uh dancing is not
in my skill set but i did
get super high one night and try to do a
couple of the
moves and i got to tell you it did not
turn out well
i no joke pulled a little muscle in my
shoulder
you know when you're getting old when
you try a dance move and mid dance move
you're like
ah dude i was out left shoulder
strain done i'm a sense teaching
hopefully joe says we can
do it okay i'm sure he won't mind man i
i just don't know if it's out is he
saving it for a special i don't know
right right but it's it's so good man
he but joe's always look man his hustle
you know he used to stand out in front
of the laugh factory with flyers you
know in vegas he used to
do the same flyers he was just standing
there pictures i sent him
uh we're talking about that this guy uh
oh what's his name
the guy who posted a picture that might
be him the guy who posted a picture of
me and him
in my first radio get our first tv gig
that was a great picture yeah and then
joe coy uh
oh yeah he said we can use it i just
said to you let's play it
yeah look at this [ __ ] because i've been
trying to get him in here and he's like
dude
i'm so busy don't worry i'm coming in
i'm coming in and then he was like i've
just been working on a ton of stuff
and i was like yeah right and they sent
me this he's worked this is what he's
working on
one of the 20 projects he's doing he is
non-stop can you turn it up jim okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
are they all korean no no different
asians
oh really but they're all asians and one
black guy
oh wow
[Music]
i'm guessing that's the black guy what
i'm sick
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't they win an award show
this is the best part
pretty dope come on man
is that cool yeah dude he is
yeah he but he never stops creating
never never stops creating and
his like when you watch his stand-up
and he goes on the road he's always
writing he's
always turning over material he's
non-stop
but he's also so [ __ ] funny have you
gone to see one of his shows i
opened for joe when was that uh last
year
did you really where uh brya i mean
his people are not no
however many shows as soon as i hit the
stage i was the only white guy they're
like get off the stage why
don't you beat it white devil
you were also three feet everybody what
yeah godzilla
no no i'm like godzilla i'm cool man i'm
here
he could if he said i'm gonna do a
hundred shows in brea he would sell out
a hundred he did 17 in a row and they
wanted to add more and he's like i just
can't
17 17 in a row so i might have been 18.
over how many days is that like two
nights over nine days no that was over
like
a certain like a week or two seven
i'm pretty sure you might sold 18 18.
they want to add more
i mean and then his merch it was just it
was dude
his merch his merch is so legit yeah
like i wear his jacket all the time but
then
just his his whole setup his sister
would run his merch like my brother runs
my merch
but then just his whole setup from the
merch until
it was like a show like he had a dj
who's on payroll
who opens up with a playlist and like as
people are sitting down he's doing the
whole thing
and they still there doing what wild
openers come on
then when joe comes he wheels them off
and then joe comes out like it was just
like
how many openers did he have he had
three
yeah man he's always made it a
performance in a show
and he's one of the guys like there are
a lot of us
who are either good with the art part or
good with the business part and and
you're good with both also man he's
really good with meshing the two
yeah he's great he's got a great
business good marketing yeah dude like
his merch is different than anybody else
is
so good it's super hit man and he's
always
sold a [ __ ] ton of merch
he used to if i'm not mistaken hang some
of it up
on the stage behind him yep so people
were just staring at it
and it's like all she's selling merch
merch i
that boy rich rich
you talk about all these yeah yeah dude
yeah he's
he's do he's not he's also the nicest
guy ever without a doubt
and this you've got a great kid man oh
that's the thing so that that's what's
up
so i got i got one thick boy brendan
schaub funko thing
and i want to sell him right and i was
like oh this is dope man i took a
picture
sent it to him and he's like oh yeah
dude cool and his son sends me a bill to
him signing
signing 5 000 of them yeah he's going to
be here all day man let me know
yeah yeah i was like all right dude by
the way how dope is that except
dude you know he so we were talking like
i was talking about some
i wasn't bragging like you know me and
him play you we play around like oh yeah
dude sold whatever
how many tickets and wherever he's all
that's cool
that's cool man he goes you know where
the warriors play i'm like
yeah isn't it like uh i forget the
neighborhood oracle yeah sold out twice
yeah the arena is yeah steph curry plays
i'm like holy [ __ ] dude
and then he goes ever heard of the form
like in la is yeah
sold that out four times yeah dude
tell me how the improv is in houston
yeah yeah
let me know that one shot the wilbur was
man yeah when you look at you're like
wait a second you sold that out twice
and you're like have i sold that many
tickets in my life isn't it nuts
it's crazy but but that's what we were
talking about
the the bubble of comedy like the amount
of people
selling think about how many tickets
gabriela glazier sells
oh that's the other thing people they
have the same manager that's the other
thing
jason uh yeah that's the other thing
people don't realize
how many tickets get fluffy
for years they have no id or how about
russell peters oh come on man
i bet you he was the top selling guy for
years maybe not right now
up there international but you're
talking people i don't think people
realize but
but in the states the states is probably
his worst market by far
he doesn't i love russell he's one of my
favorite people on earth and he's always
been great to me but
like if he's on the podcast our numbers
aren't great
but then if he sells ticket he he's you
know he's still out staple center
he stole a staple center i was driving
by it and i see russell peter i'm like
what the [ __ ]
look like he's [ __ ] so big dude it is so
amazing like
if you look at the amount of people
selling legit
tickets legit take it i mean chappelle
and rogan did the tacoma don't oh yeah
yeah hey goat this is my favorite video
it's joe coy's instagram when he sold
out
uh the form it was his dream uh dude i
get chills it chokes me up
it's him and he's like i sold out the
forum it's
nuts if you what's your spot the one
spot like if you're like your dream spot
to sell out
that's square garden yeah for me it's
it's it's td boston gardener td garden
yeah i could sell that out man
i i i don't love um i don't like
theaters but if like if you're gonna i
would love to
drink it
sell tickets dude well i did i opened
chelsea sold it out so i opened there
for her and it was crazy
it was i think she was the first comedy
act in there
is that it this video or something else
play that one
where they start singing oh yeah nope
it's before that's the dude from boys to
men yeah
okay oh they open for him yeah he did it
but you see how it comes in wait badass
are they all open for me or just him
boys demanding no
just the one yay just the one juan yeah
morris
did anybody know who he was his whole
fan base knows who
cause he always brings him with him yeah
oh he always brings boys and men with
him oh no just the lead singer
juanie morris but watch the chicks out
come on but that's the thing
joe coley is a showman dude he puts on a
show
if you're gonna do large theaters or
arenas you got it
holy [ __ ] dude you tell me people don't
walk away from that like
what a [ __ ] show oh my god
that's how he closed or open if you took
a question
to fight that is bananas
oh no the clothes it'd be tough to
follow him singing like that
and then you coming out that is because
it was
before this jen okay he's
but he's i think you're right if you're
going to play those big places it must
be a pro like
it has to be a like one of my favorite
comics in the world is mark mayer i
literally think he has the best podcast
when it comes to interviewing he's one
of my faves
but uh like mark's sitting on a stool in
arena's not gonna work no
no you need a little something i bet he
can't do it right i'm just saying like
you look at like oh here it is
it's my favorite video fizz listen to
the music
[Music]
it just got real
[Music]
crazy dude isn't that cool it gives me
chills everything i mean
are you going to like it now that's nice
he just liked that video two months ago
that's not weird yeah you go ahead yeah
that's right
it took me 30 years to get here he had
tiffany how to open for him
oh did she open for him
is that nuts it is absolutely bananas
dude
and and like i said he's so gracious
he really is gracious like when when
i've seen
people when people open for him he is
pumping you up oh yeah
he really is yeah he's a good dude man
he's got a current event
sure yeah he's one of my favorite people
dude one of my [ __ ] favorite people
i i think a group that are just like
he's like you and him are similar where
it's like you guys are just such good
people
you know like you guys are so nice so i
think i think he might have this
maybe not now but did have the same
problem where people maybe took
advantage of them being so friendly yeah
i think you're right i think you're
right but i think but you mean the last
for me it's really been a the last two
years
i've really realized i can still be
nice and not feel like i'm being taken
advantage of yeah
yep do you know what i mean like i can
still
treat people the way i want to treat
people but then when a certain point
yeah when that person when that person
starts to toe the line
i ha do you know who really helped me is
freddy
freddy freddy prince oh wow freddy was
like man
you gotta start saying no how stupid i
was like freddie mercury yeah freddie
mercury
that's where my brain was yeah freddie
martin i was like freddie mercury uh
you watched his documentary
and just the way he dealt with adversity
really inspired freddie
because i do a podcast with him yeah and
he said to me one day he was like man
you have just
got to stop he he goes you think i'm a
nice guy
i go yeah and he goes do you think
people get things past me i go no
and he goes because he grew up in the
business too long because he's like i
just say no
and i'm firm and respectful i don't say
no as like an [ __ ] yeah
i just say i'm not gonna do that or i'm
not comfortable with this yeah or we're
not doing that yeah and
i would hear him say it and i would
watch the other person's reaction
and you know i
i guess some part of me was like why are
they still gonna like me if i say no
no it's like am i burning this bridge if
i say no and i would watch the reaction
that they gave to him
and i was like oh okay it's all good
it's just they deal with it all the time
it was really it was an interesting like
i
really it has helped me so much to be
able to go
oh i don't have to do that we're gonna
get freddie in here i love freddie
man freddy will come in any time he's
the best you let me know i don't i'll be
so nice
one of the nicest a huge fighting guy
like no he's the best do you know he's
legit like not
you legit fighter but like i think
golden gloves boxer
freddie was i didn't know that dude
freddie can throw hands oh wow
and i think he's like a bro like purple
or brownie i know i knew he was like
purple i think in jitsu
yeah yeah he's the man he he he he's
such a good dude
he also knows comedy dude yeah think
about his dad
he is a comedy nurse he would go to the
the rooms you know
grew up and he goes to sleep at night
watching comedy special yeah
he he like is a comedy he's also one of
the best
chefs legit he has a cookbook out
like he does for the freddie prince
cookbook he's big
[ __ ] his instagram is all food um
yeah i i guess i hadn't noticed that i
mean
yeah yeah you gotta chill out a little
bit on the food uh that i got him that
randy
the macho man savage shirt from waiko in
kansas city oh because he used to write
for w
yeah the guys at waiko are amazing their
vintage shop the t-shirt shop i got that
randy the macho man savage
t-shirt yeah dude dude you know
um netflix is doing a thing on uh hulk
hogan
chris hemsworth is playing hulk hogan
what
i'm gonna tell you man it's gonna like
peel back the
kind of though were you a hulkster guy i
was macho man guys me too
when i get hurt as a kid instead of
crying i'd go macho man
that's how big of a fan i was yeah i
[Music]
yeah but chris hemsworth has put on
massive weight to play hulk hogan
i loved macho man i loved miss him
elizabeth
i was a warrior fan too ultimate warrior
he just not the time you know
people were like oh he's gay it's like
at the time i was like
no now i'm old i'm like oh my god you
think so
to me he just seen his warriors like out
really i think he passed away but he did
pass away was he out
yeah like what gave it away dude the
rainbow bands and the [ __ ] teased
hair all the time
but that's half of the wwe man he was
really into it
i the thing is what always struck me is
him and and
by the way i loved watching him but on
the mic he seemed like
the dummiest dummy like when you would
hear him talk and i know that was
part of the character yeah tone it down
a notch on the dumb ass
the pro my my favorite promo guy of all
time
is uh jake the snake jake the snake
because he had that real
easy way of talking oh he was good it's
scary
i like the undertaker too and i also my
favorite
promo rip of all time is when booker t
washington drops the end ball
m-bomb and st hulk hogan no no
hulk hogan come for you and says the
n-word on accident he goes up and then
the girl goes oh
i never
and you see the girl in the back like
this
it's great bring that up chin it's
fantastic you never see that what's his
name against
that booker booker two vicar washington
i think might be booker t
dude it's probably one of the first
promos that come up
randy the macho man and i i i
steroids to me right you always knew he
did steroids
but when he you remember him in
spider-man randy the moment
he looked oh he was so juicy oh
like he died like three weeks after that
dude he was he was he had veins in his
nose
like he was all get down from here
remember
and you're like are you okay dude i was
like the lines were tough to get out
he was like oh yeah and he's not getting
down from here
yo oh he's gonna have a heart attack
he's all purple
dude oh here it is turn this up oh no
watch the girl
oh let me remind this real quick like
you're normal bro look at the white girl
i can't believe you guys are seeing this
like so excited he's talking about a
click
the only click you need to know about is
the harlem heat
and something see because what you're
dealing with here
look at her it's never stopped from this
point on
in wcw we take what we want and after we
take lex luger into time we want the
gold sucker
hulk hogan we got it for you [ __ ]
oh
[Applause]
no the dude's dating character was dude
who over here man
because he knows that he's like oh yeah
he's the guy over there like
they got you're the guy in the left like
it was like this
the guy on the left was like i guess we
know who's doing the promo next week
like that dude
why not for the record
[Laughter]
oh my god it mean jane that
roll i mean jean was like dude anyways
isn't that great i i will the one thing
that always struck me when i was
watching wrestling
is you know is look they got to wear
those tiny
shorts yeah but they're so juiced up oh
they're juicy
they're i love it like yeah i'm in it
but like i think if you were gonna make
me wear something that tight
i would have to i couldn't go tiny dick
like that
no but but they they definitely do some
stuff i would have to i would have to
put like a like like um
like like a fleshlight but a fleshlight
a permanent fleshlight that is just you
put it on to make your dick look bigger
that's fair
that's actually not a terrible product
no or even like a thick gummy worm
yeah yeah something like that thick
earthworm yeah dude and you just it's
like a dick call it a dick sock
and it just makes your dick look not a
bad idea this is not a terrible idea you
say for wrestlers like i'm not wearing
it tomorrow yeah you're like wait what
for wrestlers all right let's go to
tournaments i know you're dying from
heat gin
it's warm i am did lou i don't know i
got to like yeah i know we got to figure
it out by the way i heard
him singing it seems like goddamn korean
angel
legit this you know what i'm saying
before he played me some of the because
he likes i like coming
out we love country music and so he
played me one of his songs i was like
have you done anything newton no not
recently well an old song
yeah whiskey uh the the most recent one
is the lady and write i just did a cover
yeah
crazy man you don't like did you post it
to instagram yeah later when did you
post that
a couple weeks ago really play for me
let me see later in red
by the way let me ask you i was in
nashville let me ask you your
professional opinion you've been in
nashville oh yeah a bunch
zanny's doug loves annie's i'm going to
say something that's controversial
how do you create t washington country
no hattie bees hot chicken
ah overrated you didn't like it no do
you wait in line listen it's not that i
don't like it do you wait in line though
we didn't wait tonight yeah you got a
call
okay let me just say this it's not that
i don't like it everybody i loved it
but it's overrated because
it's just hot it doesn't taste like
anything here's it's hot it's just hot
now here's another hot take no pun
intended
cat where do you get your your roll and
raise
your hall and raise no cap will you
bring in wednesday
wednesday over time it will blow your
[ __ ] mind
is it a nightmare for you to get now cat
cause no i have a hook up there
i'm telling you dude this is a chicken
it's it's hot chicken sandwiches
and it's the best in the world i'm in
i'm just saying that it's
like cat brings it cold i eat the [ __ ]
out of it i
like a cold front i'm telling you it
shits on uh whatever it had
now howdy bees i enjoy i enjoy it good
howland ray's booker t washington's that
time so
good it's so good i i would
i would compare it to you know some
people come to l.a and they're like i
mean
in and out is good but it's not like
it's overrated so for me
you they they talked it up so much that
i thought
it was hot but it didn't have a lot of
flavor like
what holidays is magical i don't hype it
up too much but it's [ __ ] mad you do
a booger t washing promo after you eat
that thing it's
so good i'm i'm ready that sandwich
right there because i like a little
coleslaw
i like it messy dude give me a coleslaw
and pickle
sandwich although
i i oh my god i'm gonna [ __ ] for like a
day after
it's dude i'm telling you it's worth it
you didn't say you didn't hear me say i
wasn't gonna eat it i hear you dude
just trying to convince you to [ __ ] your
pants yeah i'm saying what do you got
let's go it is howling raised were they
based off somewhere
uh chinatown the guy is originally i
think
from the south him and his best friend
moved out here and started their own
restaurant
cat has a little too much inside yeah
yeah
he's actually a really nice guy i'm
obsessed with that
his son is in second grade yeah she's
actually really kind
i'm obsessed with that place when you go
in there all of the workers are so cool
do they know you yeah they'll give you
like free shift they see you a couple
times
it's so nice in chinatown that's another
weird thing
it's it's an uh a hole in the wall
basically
by the way that's how i when i eat
chinese food
i don't know if i told you this like i
don't want my chinese food restaurant to
have an
a in the window no i i'm looking for c's
and b's i
i want to walk in and i either want to
think this is either going to be the
most authentic tasting thing i've ever
had or i'm going to have
hot diarrhea for about a year you want
season b's just like you want your kid
getting season b's dude like the most
the most rich people in the world get
season beats you know what when i when i
walk into a chinese restaurant
i want to see like a little asian kid
doing math by the cash register
and his grandmother yelling at him in
china you know what i mean
dude it should look like the opening
scene of gremlins like one of those like
where you're like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah like that's what i want yeah
or i want to look like big trouble of
little children yeah exactly it's a
little
yeah yeah yeah yeah probably haunted
whatever
who is what's this so this is bella
thorne she was
a disney actress when she was a kid
she's now an adult
and she announced the other day that she
was gonna have an only fans account
and she crashed the site when she
launched they weren't ready for
they weren't ready for it uh her rates
start at twenty dollars to sixty dollars
and they're estimating that she's gonna
make a million dollars a month
what what for naked pictures or just
you could post whatever you want on only
hold on before i react how old
cat 22. okay so far
where was i yeah she's
ridiculous she's super hot
it's that's the time she has 23 million
followers
i think the appeal is also that she was
on disney but
is she posting nudes on this you could
it doesn't necessarily mean she is she
just says that she's launching an
only fan's account and she already posts
up kind of risque photos of herself
so we don't know exactly what's going to
be on there but you like my boy stevie
blue eyes his girlfriend's
you know one of the biggest porn stars
in the world who's his girlfriend um
something annis uh uh annis or amy cool
is that a nice way nicole anderson
oh anderson i think he said anna i'm
like we pronounce it you don't work
nichola aniston
i don't she's a beast in a good way but
so but what's interesting is he goes you
don't real like
it's only fans has changed the game for
porno stars because
now there's no set there's no like they
don't have to pay anybody a fee
right they do only fans a bunch of times
a week and they're making
stupid money so that million dollars
doesn't surprise me at all because i
know how much some of these other girls
make
because now they're just like posting
like nicole's posting
you know [ __ ] stevie and it's just
for only fans and then
they don't have to upload to you porn or
nothing he's posting [ __ ] stevie
you're stevie's a porno star opener is a
partner
porno star so now i'm gonna have to get
familiar with her work
you should because i'm gonna have to at
least look you know if he's a friend of
a friend i gotta look you gotta look
yeah i mean you gotta look
wait so stevie's packing heat
i mean not you know sun's heat but
right yeah yeah but okay bigger than
shaq how
i'm listen i'm gonna i just i can't
believe it
i can't believe that it's something that
big don't go to heat.com and you'll see
how much would it cost you so say i was
gonna tell you listen
b you're gonna make a million a month on
an only fans account but it's gotta be
[ __ ] and ball shots
of like me jerking off no just whatever
only fans whatever they're doing
i don't know what all they do on yeah
i'm so like do they make requests
uh i don't know you cat gets demands all
the time
what do you mean
i tried like it was like maybe you like
this i'm like all right well let me see
what and i'm like
it's weird dude it doesn't look right
i don't i don't and also feet are bigger
than hands so then it's like these big
feet and this dick and it's like even to
get size dick
yeah like feet are pretty big and by the
way just a size of girl six is pretty
big you know what feels better than feet
a [ __ ] yeah all every time even a mouth
a hundred percent of the time a hund
without a doubt don't take even a mouth
like it's not
that's fantastic feet would be my
last i can think of i go five other body
parts i'd rather
yeah i go mouth vagina
ass ass without a doubt dude
both hands both of my hands titties
titties i mean we are dead i even go
next you're walking i'm gonna get your
neck if you're fat sure i might
i'd definitely go armpit before i go if
you're fat yeah yeah you can't have some
skinny [ __ ] with her
armpit on me yeah i i mean i'd be armed
i'd be pitted before i'd be
footed foot it's weird i just i tried
getting into it man i watched a video
i'm like what's the deal there's this
little lady this little asian girl had
her feet on but they're like this
triangle
yeah the vagina's right there the whole
setup is weird the vagina's right there
i know
i've never been and it looks complicated
also
dude do this for a minute her
thighs must be on fire in her hands
do this for a minute yeah try this for a
minute but you try this for a minute you
can do this all
right
i'll
[Applause]
because your feet are going to be kind
of together oh dude this
for a minute dude yeah but i i don't
i've never had a foot job like that i've
tried to [ __ ] the feet
in between like that like in the you
know what's the for the
oh the webbing yeah no like nothing like
that [ __ ] the fish
when i think about the webbing of a feet
no but like if you're like this you put
your dick in between the flat into it
dude
and you grease it up not into it that's
footing but i'm gonna
but no they're not doing the movement oh
you're [ __ ] in the face yeah yeah
yeah yeah
well that's not fun neither one is fun i
mean it's just the other one
like take my money because it must be
exhausting i will tell you this
the one thing and i was curious about
this i know it's gonna sound stupid
because i did it twice the first time
i was like okay i want to do that again
because
i almost was like it was like an olympic
sport i'm like i want to see how far
up i can i can make it oh
so if you're here the first time i had
it angled down wrong so it ended here
but i'm like i wonder if i can make so i
was just trying to go for a distance i
was going for distance but at my age
there's not a lot of distance no that
game's a pass no
yeah it's
it's like because you you want it like
sometimes you're like this is gonna be a
[ __ ]
yeah that's gonna and then it just goes
yeah it just goes yeah you're that damn
that is not
exactly what i want oh man porno stars
and only fans
that's it's like it's like kind of out
the middle man it's almost you know it's
like
i would do it for six months
to make six mil quick and then maybe
drop out
yeah i don't know you got young kids my
kids are old they already are you know
you're a good dude my kid's like what
the
[ __ ] and you didn't need to do it nope
yeah oh that left you didn't need to
no just wanted to try something new we
were living in this house
the money i but what's her like she's
what but she has such a huge following
what's she been doing like how she gets
so big
she recently started directing porn too
interesting oh oh okay well i know but
she was she ends
up huge she's not important i don't know
if that makes a big difference
but her porn mate won an award too i
believe i think
so yeah at the avns so this is like jake
my son's age like this is who
so when you say he's going to make a
million 500 000
is because my son logged in yeah he's
you know what i mean like
that age group it's like
when you used to tune in to that tv
channel because you thought you might
get a fuzzy titty
yeah so she may never have to actual
post nudes
no as long as people think she might the
next time
what did she post about quentin
tarantino
that's your guy your birthday okay i
thought she was like hating on him or
something no that's your guy yeah
[ __ ] yeah wow yeah i'm a fan i mean i
don't know what she does but
here's the thing like people making bank
in all sorts of different ways good for
them especially on pandemic
the the only fans i've seen a lot of
people start to go
to the only fans they must be making
a ton but it's like the patreon for
people who want to show their tits right
patreon patreon patreon patreon it's for
hardcore fans now is that that is a
one-time payment or it's a monthly thing
like
it's a monthly subscription wow
everything's subscription now
i would well she's a very pretty girl
if you okay if you're a dad do these
pictures bother you you sure do
it's so interesting like they sure do
these
these pictures
oh it's tough man especially in 2020
yeah
because you know what it is look we all
you hope that this isn't the rest of the
life but as a young woman
especially a disney star when you're
kept under such
lock and key sure i'm sure there's a
period where like i
i'm going to show my body i want to show
what i look like i want to show
everybody how good-looking i am and i
want to be a grown-up
that's the best thing it's just tough
when you have kids and
now it's social media like these posts
your kids are going to be able to get a
lot of this stuff
oh you mean 10 years from now 15 years
from now
is there anything that you can think of
that you are like man i hope they don't
see that i did that
no i mean they're gonna there's gonna be
a archive of
just me talking [ __ ] right where
they're gonna get a real
good just when i pass if they want to
listen to it yeah holy [ __ ] dad was a
dumbass yeah yeah he did this all the
time
you know are you going to show them your
fights uh
he asked the other day for because i'm
always watching sees me watching it
and then i showed him he's like jesus
christ because it doesn't really look
like we have a shaved head yeah he's
like that's you papa boom boom because
it
uh pow pow like that's pop dad doing pow
pow
he's like why would you do that and then
we were driving the other day he goes
i'm gonna do pow pow
no you're not you don't want him to
fight no hell no
no rich kid listen name the best
toughest rich kid you know right now not
that i'm that rich but i'm just saying
like no normally the kids don't come
from that like he's gonna have too many
options be a fighter
do you oh you think people get into
fighting because they don't have options
100 yeah the best ones don't do it
because
they could have went to you know mit
no i understand that but like are you
saying
especially because my son's not gonna be
small right like both of them be big
they're gonna play football like there's
no guarantee fighting's too rough
like you know dana white's the most
famous man in mixed martial arts he goes
fighting is not a career it's just what
he say it is
in it's opportunity it's not a career
though he's like this business isn't a
career for anybody
because it's except for the very few
it's a three year what's the average i
think two and a half two and a half
years
that's like a running back in the nfl
yeah even theirs is three and a half
yeah but the running back in the nfl is
at least guaranteed a certain amount of
money he's at least getting money
but one of these is not clear this
opportunity you know so he's just like
do you think there will be a point in
time
because right now to me all of the best
athletes
play either football or basketball
because it's life-changing money
the only one making life-changing money
in the ufc is conor mcgregor
so d you don't think there'll be a time
where you see
like some of the great athletes be like
you know what
that's what i want to do as opposed to
basketball or footballer too tough
it's too tough it's not the first option
it's just not
yeah it's two like in punch in the face
it's not fun no the practices are a
nightmare
like there's no off season the notoriety
is not even close to what you'd get if
you're like you know in the nba
or well the guarantees the corrupt
you know like there's steps to get to
the nfl the steps get the nba
there's no steps for ufc you know it's
just it's just a tough go man
the best athletes aren't going to go
into it and they're also seeing how many
people are [ __ ] over
because for every conor mcgregor in the
nba they're all making more than come
right you know they're like
you know granted he had 100 million
dollar fight but for the majority all
those guys getting guaranteed money
conor's a once in a two billion fighters
i mean even the last
who's the lie who who's who's the 12th
person in the lakers bench you think
i mean who do you think the white guy
who has terrible hair
uh cruz or whatever but how and how much
but the minimum
what they what are they making they're
making guaranteed money you know
are they the you think people to put
average nba contracts do you think the
average nba contract take away the top
three in the ufc you think the average
nba contract is better than
some people what they make up top ten
not even close i think
like 7.7 is the average salary and
that's guaranteed right
the average ufc contract i think is 30
grand
so i okay so so back me up a little bit
what's the mo
so so it is all they can do
look at that dude that's
earns about 138 000 so corn industry the
average ufc fighter earns about 138 000
on an annual basis well ahead of the 45
000 year average
yeah but they're only making it for a
finite amount of time and is that 138
000
and that's after they pay their manager
uh nope nope that's probably
what on contract they have on paper so
138 grand and so
and when you sign a contract for the ufc
you sign by the fight it's
usually a six fight deal six fight deal
so you've
you know ahead of time or can you
negotiate say you
kill it the first two fights can you go
you know what dana i i want more of this
third fight
if you like let's say you have a six
fight deal and four fights under
contract you're
you're fighting for a title you can
renegotiate but even then that's like up
in the air
and is the sixth fight seems like a
[ __ ] lot
and it seems to be weighed two years
six fights two years yeah if you're
really active
i i just remember six fights is two to
three two two
three fight as much no way no way like
boxers don't fight
nearly as much is that because they get
hit more boxing's just a different
animal the thing when you think about
the cards there's not many fighters on
there the big names fight once a year
maybe twice a year
but why so i i think i did read that
that boxers just get hit more
they hit more for sure they get hit more
yeah do you think that's why they don't
fight as much
do you think a there's not enough thing
about like the ufc has a card every
weekend until the end of the year like
boxing it's like
that was for recovery like how long does
it take to recover from a fight
it just depends how the fight went but
you know you're talking like
you know guys get 60 day suspensions 90
day suspensions
after a fight how long would it take you
say the i don't know what's the fight
that the camps are that beat you up
you know you're in camp for 12 weeks you
know then you do the fight you need a
break man
yeah again there's no off season like my
kid's super half like the fighting's the
last thing you
you know how much money they can make if
they're permanent premier league soccer
player
yeah because of the high speed i know
like
it's so guaranteed money or baseball
guaranteed money
baseball guarant that guaranteed money
in baseball is
and the other thing no head trauma in
your worst injury what you
do john surgery you watch you watch
basketball you watch
you watch the i love the nba and tnt i
love
chuck and kenny and shaq together but
when they get up and run to the board
yeah to see how hard it is for those
guys to walk
now they're big dudes right baseball
players don't have the way
baseball you know over here they don't
have any of that
limp or anything nothing but also
the those guys like charles barkley's
what 6 10
no no 6'5 no barkley's six five has to
be six seven
six five let's say six eight six say six
eight charles barkley's six i say six
five power four
yes i know he did but he was one of his
thing was that he was super short six
six six
yeah he was he dude what a freak to be
able to six six and jump amongst those
trees
mvp what a freak you know what one of my
favorite body type athletic body type
is the chubby athletic dude that's why i
loved chris farley
daniel cormier dude love it man when
you're like i'm
there's no way that dude is in anything
you're like did he just do a triple
reverse flip
first team all dad man yo when chris
farley used to do uh
uh uh what are those called handstands
and cartwheels
i'm like come on man el sasso super
athletic easy yeah
sasso's athletic that's cast like this
but if you're a big dude
you got calves yes like big you gotta
carry the weight yeah man
you know if you're over 300 pounds you
wear shorts in the winter you know what
i mean those guys yeah you're right
yeah that's right fat guys always have
giant cats
you know what is that that's will
sasso's calf
get why is it bigger than my thigh
his thighs are also not small
yeah that that his head his calves is
close to his size of his face
and will's killing man has his own show
now on tv
what is it uh i forget the show it looks
really good reminds the kings of queens
really yeah oh yeah i did see a
commercial for that man
it looks really good united we fall
all right give us one more current event
i get picked tiger about three
alrighty
too much about that one what'd you say i
just started following her on instagram
halle berry
she's so hot she's 50. oh my gosh she's
51. yeah
i'll just pick one i just gift
i it's that's catwoman dude it's
mind-blowing
and sam like i've seen in person i've
never seen her in for everything i've
seen so
i'm a hiking person i when i saw selma
hiking person
and i was just like what is happening
right now we'll risk everything for it
it it's it's
and by the way this to me there's
something super
sexy about a woman over 50 who looks
like salmon height
and hallelujah by the way my wife
if you if nobody my wife also smoke show
bring up a picture of bethany wolfe man
yeah you're right again
dude she is we have thick girl dropping
uh
thick girl merch dropping on friday and
they're like oh we need a mall or
something like that i'm like
if you need a hot thick girl my wife is
the hottest thick girl
look at her see look at yeah your wife
is get smoke
out of here dude what am i doing with
that does she have only fans account
[Music]
i'm gonna ask her it's not she want to
make bank or not dude because
i would subscribe yeah she's looking
she's like
who's the old dude next to that
she and dude like that is
what look at that that pink shirt she
took this picture
last year how old is she 50 jesus
zero workski zero
and her body is banging she was on
church she went she went on joey's show
yeah dude but there's something about
how
over 50 that that they carry themselves
with such
confidence yeah they don't have to try
something no
it's so uh sexy it's crazy
do you and her have kids together we do
not you don't no
uh you wish you did that's a great
question
yes and no yes because 19 kids
right yes because it's such a crazy look
at her god
it is such a cool thing to experience
with somebody else
but we did she really raised
my kids you know i was on the road bro
because you
you got together with her how long ago
uh 2001
is when we first started dating 19 years
yeah man and so she's been she's
when i've been on the road attractive
couple both of you guys are it's like
nobody out kicked their coverage
i out kicked mine you're a good looking
dude but look at this look at how old
are you
50. look at most 50 year olds men
i know have yeah either gonna be rich
like creepy
you know what i'm glad never started
happening to me you know when all guys
some guys get older that one eye starts
to close the sniper right
and you're like what the [ __ ] oh were
you in vietnam
i was not i was not why is your one just
getting old
yeah i would just tell you i was a
sniper is your left eye giving up bro
yeah i did like what the [ __ ]
got his lids done because of it yeah was
his dropping oh yeah
both were dropping oh he was getting
heavy lived yeah he couldn't see oh
that's not good he looks exactly the
same but whatever
he that wasn't gonna say it but yeah all
right give us this last one all right i
don't know who this is exactly but i
guess he's some sort of famous mountain
biker
but check out this trick he did holy
[ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] hard pass for me oh
on rocks i wonder what kind of shock you
guys
that yes was a thank god he didn't die
yes that's just insane absolutely
saint george yes that's in utah i got so
many questions
question number one like how do you
practice that
he probably does it on a ramp into the
soft and on the soft pit
but that's his ideal descent
i wonder what bike he was like the
but he's also it looks like he's a
motorcyclist too right yeah
looks like he does all that stuff those
dudes are different
yeah it's just not especially the guys
that flip those bikes
[Music]
can you tell are you looking at the bike
yeah i can't tell
do you see how they have the downhill
shocks see how the shocks start
at the handlebars yeah see this one look
look at this
but jesus christ
here's another reason why these people
are they're a different breed
so he's not wearing any protection on
the upper half of his body
just the head so if he falls his
entire back and chest is gonna be one
giant open
wound see if it's almost like like these
guys like it's far f and few between who
make real money
so it's like you're trying to be this
guy or a ufc fighter like there's really
no
difference but the ufc guys have to make
more than these guys
who like travis persona you know what
i'm saying like some of those guys like
some of those guys make real money dude
i'm just not
like extreme sports guys i i
i there's nothing in my dna when i see
that kind of stuff it makes me go
oh i got to do it nothing in my dna
that looks like a yt bike it is what
does he ride one of the same bikes
that's a yt industry bike
what would it take for you and your size
to be able to do a flip like that i
don't know don't want to find out yeah
it's just not i'm just not into it you
might need it it's that's that's
like [ __ ] dude you might need some extra
i need to do i need a i need a
motorcycle yeah you can also it's like
like you get hurt doing that like i
don't be hurt coming here with a [ __ ]
cast and you broke a crank too yeah i
break cranks and [ __ ] i'm too big for
the
it's a nightmare yeah i mean that's dope
man that's dope
shout out to yt industries and this
guy's name is ethan nell
shout to ethan nell yt team yt
um all right man i pick up my kiddo oh
yeah dude i gotta run and
we love you man dude thanks for having
me what are you talking about doing
wednesday
you tell me man i sent you some ideas
but i thought i said something
didn't i howling race that oh for sure
talon raised wednesday yeah i mean now
helen ray's not coming in here but the
sandwiches
yeah by the way i i don't give a [ __ ] if
yeah he comes in
yes dude yeah tell us about your
sandwich that's always the worst
dude when people are like i'd love to
come to your podcast man and talk
like no i'm telling you it's not gonna
work you know what gets me is
and i know i do love people who are
passionate about what they do i do
but i don't need to know how you cooked
it no no no no
just put it down and also you don't need
to be on the show and tell us no no
people don't give a [ __ ]
like when they come over like someone's
like the chef would like to tell you how
you're prepared
i don't know not into it dude okay not
into it
i'm happy you're happy but like but i'll
i'll entertain it but i just i'm telling
you i'm not into it no i
i don't think it's strange people like
weave saute the that dude i don't
give a you might as well speaking french
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i'm never good
is it good
cool i'm not can you tell somebody else
and then like if someone gives me the
cliff notes
on the way out it's fun yeah it is
strange yeah i'm not my thing man well
we love you man any more uh road dates
what are you doing i have a lot of road
dates on fire so who knows
at the end of september and october i
got a lot of road dates coming up
but just keep checking out my stuff man
and again a huge thanks to
the people who reached out and to share
their stories with me it was it was
truly humbling so it was super cool but
my website has everything and
check out my youtube page and my
facebook page i put out new content
your merch is crushing it too man uh
yeah the merch is
[Music]
forward slash josh shop.upstatemerch.com
that's a lot that's tough yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can't do that at
joshua.com yeah it's on this one right
here joshua.com
the comedian joshua my special's on
there and you can come in love it man
yeah you're all over man
yeah bro that's september i hate that no
that
boise just closed boise is closed but so
i'm just getting a chance the orange
peel
uh yes north carolina could happen
nashville and then punchline atlanta and
then i'm through
in october atlanta's gonna happen yes in
october i'm in like uh
columbus and uh funny bone yeah i love
that
me too oh there we go columbus liberty
township
omaha omaha the triple door seattle
yeah that's a little the other one shut
down seattle you know that
they wanted tacoma they want to seattle
seattle and bellevue
oh yeah yeah yeah but that had a club
remember the club that would start
during your late show saturday yeah yeah
so you'd be like
and people like what the [ __ ] the whole
crowd's like what that club shut down
though
yeah it was a great club i enjoyed it
poorly ran great club though
i did like that you never had to go
outside because the hotel was attached
by a sky bridge yeah that's cool
so you could just walk into the mall and
eat and never actually actually
i'm doing uh i'm doing awesome
new stuff i'm doing austin end of
september and their their first
week that uh cap city is opening
september first
so we're like we're hoping it happens
then of uh september
that's austin uh september 24th 26th
actually going out early looking at
houses nice and then
dallas is october 1st through the 3rd
nashville
i'll see you there brother yes nashville
is november 19th through 21st again
the world's on fire who knows but that's
the plan right now yeah and check out my
facebook and youtube pages guys
stick girl drops this friday along with
thick boy authentic nba jerseys that's
at thickboy.com
all right man we love you thanks for
having me